these are foods that are made because
the government helps support these
commodity crops which are 60
of our calories that people consume them
the most are the sickest
globally it kills 11 million people a
year that's like a holocaust
every single year people dying from
eating the wrong foods and not eating
the right foods
and it's because our whole agricultural
system has been moved to make those
foods
which are causing heart disease diabetes
cancer
dementia obviously obesity
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report and joining me today is a doctor
who is a leader in the field of
functional medicine
as well as a 13-time new york times
best-selling author
uh and his newest book is food fix how
to save our health our economy our
communities and our planet
one bite at a time dr mark hyman welcome
to the reuben report thanks for having
me dave
i think that was my longest intro ever i
mean this is a seriously updated because
that book just hit the list yesterday
yeah that was i'm doing this on the
timeline you can see as i edited it
right there
it said 12 on the on the prompt i'm
super psyched to talk to you because as
i just said to you before we started
getting away a little bit
from politics is always a nice break for
me yes but this is not
purely a way from politics so we're
going to do a little of that
food is probably the most political
issue of our time even though we don't
talk about it that way
yeah and and quite literally you bit off
a lot in this title because you talked
about
economics and communities and the planet
and all of those things
and how it's related so before we get
into any of that stuff
how did you get into this field what
made you care about all of this stuff
where did it all come from that's great
well i've always been interested in
health nutrition i grew up
in spain my parents lived there for 11
years after the war they missed the
whole junk food fast food
processed food revolution america and i
always grew up eating real whole food
and in college i lived with a guy who
was a nutrition phd student
and he introduced me this whole idea
about nutrition against disease
and i became a yoga teacher before as a
doctor then i became a doctor and kind
of got indoctrinated
literally and became
very focused on you know traditional
good medicine but i realized the limits
of it and i
then got sick myself and ended up having
to fix myself using functional medicine
which is
looking at systems and looking at root
causes and after 30 years of sitting in
my office seeing chronically ill
patients
which by the way is 6 out of 10
americans have a chronic disease
that kills 11 million people a year from
food
i realized that food was causing my
patients to be sick
and that i had to look at why they were
eating the food they were eating
and then i thought well it's the food
system i'm like well why do we have the
food system it's our food policies
and why do we have our policies it's
because of the food industry influence
driving our policies and some of its
legacy from good intentions that we
still have from policies fifteen to
seven years ago so
occurred to me that if i really want to
cure my patients
i have to step back and look at the big
picture of what's wrong with our food
system
the impact it's causing on disease on
our economy
on social justice issues poverty mental
health kids academic performance
national security environment climate
it's all one problem
that is predominantly driven by our food
and our food system and it's fixable
if food is the cause it's also the cure
and that's exactly what this book is
about um so you know it's called food
fix not food apocalypse
we'll see about that give me another 50
minutes here um
so you know i i had your buddy max
lugavir on recently and
he was also talking about how fun how
regular western medicine when his mom
got sick um they did not have enough
answers or it was as he calls it
diagnose and adios
you you just referenced something there
about indoctrination and
uh relative to western medicine yeah and
how they don't really talk about food
can you explore that a little bit yeah
one
barry says you know the food system
produces food with no paying no
attention to health
and the health care system treats
disease with no attention to food
and i think food is the biggest driver
of chronic disease it's something that
i've learned as as a functional medicine
doctor that food is medicine
and can heal but it also can harm and so
that's really why i wrote this book was
to
sort of help our country and hopefully
our global population
understand that if we want to deal with
some of the biggest crises we're facing
today
in america and globally we have to focus
on the food system it's the most
invisible cause
it's there's no real conversation about
it in the political discourse
and yet it's probably the biggest
political issue of our time so since
we're having the conversation right now
what are some of just like the basic
things we should know
about the foods we're eating and and
what we're being force-fed that we
shouldn't
eat and maybe some things that right we
should be incorporating all that exactly
so how we grow food from the seed
to how we produce food and process food
to how we eat it
and how we waste it is driving so much
of our issues
so the food we're producing
predominantly today is what we call
ultra
processed calories or ultra processed
food what is that
it's food made from a few simple
ingredients refined white flour
high fructose corn syrup and other corn
additives and ingredients
and refined soybean oil that are turned
into literally hundreds of thousands of
processed foods
that are all made from the same
ingredients that are different colors
sizes and shapes of
food like extruded substances yeah and
and and the
frightening thing is the data they're
not fresh that's what you're doing well
they're not
fresh they're ingredients you might even
recognize we read
if you cover the front of a pop tart or
a corn dog
of the box you probably could barely
tell the difference in the ingredients
right
and and these are foods that are made
because the government helps support
these commodity crops which are sixty
percent of our calories
the people consume them the most are the
sickest globally it kills 11 million
people a year that's like a holocaust
every single year people dying from
eating the wrong foods and not eating
the right foods
and it's because our whole agricultural
system has been moved to make those
foods which are causing heart disease
diabetes cancer dementia obviously
obesity and it's
frightening to me when i was born there
were
five percent of americans who were obese
when i graduated medical school
it was less than 20 percent there was
not a single state that had an obesity
rate over 20 percent
now it's 42 and most states have obesity
rates over 40 percent
that's 42 percent of americans are obese
75 overweight
it's going to be one in two people in 10
years that will be obese not just
overweight
and this is crippling our economy we now
have
one in three dollars in medicare it's
spent for diabetes alone
our entire chronic disease epidemic 80
of medicare costs are from
chronic disease we have one in
three federal dollars that are spent on
medicare soon it will be one in two
i mean medicare for our company would be
the biggest company in the world with a
1.3
trillion a year budget wow and and
a lot of that is unnecessary 80 of that
is unnecessary
this caused by the food and the food
system so you mentioned the way our
policies going back decades sort of
led to some of these um is there like a
moment
yeah so so here's what happened you know
nobody was like a big cabal of evil food
companies that got together
because i think that i'm glad you
started with that because i think that's
what people think that it's like these
evil
companies or the evil government that
sit down and how do we screw over the
most amount of people
it's the unintended consequences of good
intentions right
so after the world war ii there was a
lot of hunger in the world
there was a need to produce a lot of
starchy calories which we thought were
good
sources of carbohydrates and energy to
fuel a growing population
and so industrial agriculture came onto
the scene
with you know mass mechanization with
intensive use of fertilizers pesticides
herbicides
which no one knew were bad at the time i
mean silent spring was written in the
60s by rachel carson
which exposed the harm of ddt and
pesticides that wasn't eliminated until
the 70s
and we didn't know that fertilizer was
destroying oceans and lakes and rivers
and
killing you know hundreds of thousands
of tons of fish every year and they're
going to
like nobody know i mean nobody yeah i
don't i don't believe that people really
said oh these pesticides are going to
kill people we're going to use them
anyway or that
glyphosate is going to cause cancer and
destroy your microbiome
and you think these companies they
really yes they thought they had answers
yeah of course and we needed to create a
food for a growing population
uh but then people started to understand
these things and then the
cat was out of the bag and they didn't
want to lose the the business and the
profitability of
growing food in this way if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about lifestyles instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell